>>> HEY, EMMA.
WELCOME BACK.
>> HEY, MELISSA.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN?
>> FRICKIN' GREAT.
I'M SO HAPPY.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
I MEAN LAST TIME I WAS HERE, IT
WAS YOUR FIRST SEASON, RIGHT?
>> YEP.
AND I'VE GROWN SO MUCH SINCE
THEN.
ESPECIALLY IN THE
SELF-LOVE/CONFIDENCE DEPARTMENT.
>> HMM.
WELL, THAT'S COOL.
I'LL SEE YA.
>> I JUST HAD TO LOOK AT MYSELF
AND SAY, HEY, YOU'RE COOL,
MELISS.
LET YOURSELF REJOICE IN WHO YOU
ARE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I FOUND A LOT OF PEACE THROUGH
MY HOBBIES.
>> THAT'S NEAT.
>> HEY, YOU WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THEM?
>> I MEAN I HAVE TO LEARN --
>> GREAT.
I'M GOING TO RAP.
THE HOBBY ENTHUSIASTS
WHEN I'M NOT AT WORK, WHAT DO I
DO?
I DO SEXY MELISSA THINGS THAT
THAT'S ME ALL RIGHT
LATE AT NIGHT DRAWING
ON MY FACE JUST RIGHT
I'M DOING A SELF-PORTRAIT
THESE ARE MY HOBBIES
SMELLING MY BOOKS
I LIKE DRAWING PAINTING
I LIKE NAPPING WAKING UP
>> WAIT, HOLD UP.
GANDALF?
>> HMM-MM.
I WAKE UP AND GO, THAT WAS A
GOOD NAP.
>> AWESOME.
AND YOU SMELL YOUR BOOKS?
>> OH, YEAH, YOU GOT TO SMELL
BOOKS.
>> I'M SORRY TO DO THIS BUT I
REALLY HAVE TO GET GOING.
>> I'M ALMOST DONE, THOUGH.
>> OKAY.
SICK BINOCULARS
SO I COULD BIRD WATCH AND
J-J-J-JEALOUS
YEAH, YOU'RE JEALOUS.
I LIKE SCREAMING SINGING
HUGGING MY BACKPACK
I LIKE SILENCE KARATE
>> EVERYONE WANTS MY ART
SUPPLIES THAT ARE INSIDE MY
BACKPACK.
GET YOUR OWN.
>> WE NEED EMMA ON SET.
EMMA STONE TO THE SET, PLEASE.
>> OH, SHOOT.
THEY NEED ME ON SET.
SO ANNOYING.
>> YEAH, NO, THAT SOUNDS
ANNOYING.
ALMOST AS ANNOYING AS WHEN
SOMEONE INTERRUPTS YOU WHILE
YOU'RE RAPPING ABOUT YOUR
HOBBIES.
>> I DON'T THINK I'VE
INTERRUPTED.
>> TWICE.
YOU'VE INTERRUPTED TWICE.
EMMA STONE?
MORE LIKE, I'M A STONE, BECAUSE
STONES DON'T HAVE FEELINGS.
AND THAT'S YOU.
>> I AM NOT A STONE.
THE TRUTH IS I DO HAVE A HOBBY.
I WAS JUST EMBARRASSED.
>> NEVER BE EMBARRASSED OF YOUR
HOBBY.
IT'S A PART OF YOU.
>> I'M GOING TO RAP NOW.
OF FIGURINES
I'VE BEEN CARVING THEM
AND I'M THE QUEEN
IT'S THE CUTEST LITTLE
AND PETER THE JESTER
AND THE TOWN GOSSIP
WHO'S FULL OF SECRETS
A WHOLE LOT MORE THAT
>> MELISSA TO SET, PLEASE.
>> OH, YOU HEARD HIM.
I GOTTA GO.
>> WELL, HEY MAYBE WE COULD
SEE --
AND SHE'S GONE.